et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc aurore bergé bonjour merci d'être
avec nous est député et vice président
délégué du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée nationale et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour julien
lécuyer bonjour au royaume de la voie
d'une évidemment julien lécuyer on va
parler du pads maximale puisque le sénat
a donc donné son feu vert cette nuit un
texte voté mais modifiée on va revenir
sur le fond des modifications comment
vous réagissez à ce vote du sénat ce oui
mais des sénateurs bah c'est un peu ce
que j'allais vous dire c'est à dire
c'est justement oui mais c'est à dire
que si c'est voter le post vaccinale
mais le voter dans des conditions telles
qu'en vérité il a de moins en moins de
sens et d'efficacité c'est plus vraiment
le post vaccinale qui est voté et c'est
tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui de la
commission mixte paritaire moi je
souhaite qu'elle puisse aboutir parce
que je souhaite que le pass vaccinale
entre en vigueur parce que encore une
fois on a besoin et c'est ce qu'on dit
depuis le début d'ajouter plus de
contraintes sur celles et ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés pour des raisons
évidentes encore une fois de santé
publique je me suis rendu encore au
centre de réanimation de rambouillet
quête sur ma circonscription
100 % des lits sont occupés par des
cagots vide 85% sur des personnes non
vaccinées le reste des personnes qui
n'avaient rien perdu en première fois
qu'on voit sur les modifications
apportées par le sénat serait moins
efficace pour le pass vaccinale alors il
y en a plusieurs deux modifications et
qui sont des modifications
substantielles ya des modifications sur
la question du télétravail or les
premiers retours qu'on a sur la
mobilisation du télétravail on voit que
ça n'est pas suffisant par rapport à ce
qu'on aurait pu espérer que c'est vrai
qu'à supprimer les amendes pour les
questions quelle est la contrainte
potentiel sur des entreprises on avait
essayé de mettre une contrainte qui
était proportionné on peut peut-être en
discuter du montant de cette contrainte
mais il faut bien une contrainte pour un
moment mesurer l'efficacité et garantir
que ce soit mis en place donc ça vous
fait est que ce soir il ya en tout cas
je vous dis les différences kia et après
c un débat est peut-être un compromis
qui peut essayer d'être retrouvé ensuite
il ya la question d' à partir de quel
âge le pass vaccinale serait ou non
demander le compromis qu'on a trouvé à
l'unanimité à l'assemblée nationale qui
était d'ailleurs sur proposition de
députés de divers groupes c'est que ce
soit à partir de 16 ans pourquoi 16 ans
parce qu'à partir de 16 ans vous avez la
liberté de choisir si vous souhaitez ou
non vous faire vacciner en deçà de 16
ans ça dépend de vos parents donc si vos
parents refusent que vous le soyez
quelque part vous subissez la décision
qui n'est pas la vôtre donc on avait
trouvé ce compromis le sénat a dit ce
sera 18 ans que je trouve incohérente
parce que souvent les sénateurs ou les
groupes lr vous disent il faut que vous
tout de suite beaucoup plus de
responsabilités parfois sur des sujets
bien plus graves notamment en termes de
responsabilité pénale ensuite il ya la
question des seuils qui pour moi est
beaucoup plus grave à mettre dans le dur
de la loi parce qu'aujourd'hui dire qu
on supprimerait le pass vaccinale en
fonction d'un seuil d'hospitalisation
c'est finalement
se mettre en risque parce que encore une
fois je peux tout à fait comprendre la
question posée fondamentale qui et
combien de temps ça va durer oui c'est
celle que se posent les français c'est
de savoir en fait si on va pas se
retrouver avec une restriction des
libertés à bitam aeternam mais ça cette
question là elle est fondamentale sur la
question des libertés publiques et de l'
équilibre à trouver entre protection
sanitaire mais aussi protection sociale
économique psychologique même parce que
évidemment ça crée ça peut créer des
tensions en revanche posées dans la loi
des critères sur des seuils à établir ou
non on peut se dire que là les seuils
correspondrait peut-être à la vague que
nous connaissons au risque que nous
avons avec ce variant est ce que pour
autant ce serait le bon seuil si demain
nous avions un autre verre vous voyez
aussi le temps de la discussion
parlementaire et c'est normal s'appelle
la vie démocratique nous on revient
devant le parlement de manière
systématique mais ça veut dire que si on
devait demain changer le seuil parce
qu'il était inscrit dans la loi ces deux
semaines trois semaines quatre semaines
de débat parlementaire puis déférée au
conseil conçu et donc ça veut dire un
risque d'absence de réactivité alors
qu'on sait très bien qu'on a besoin de
s'adapter en permanence alors que ne
siègera pas entre mai et juillet donc
pour vous ça c'est un problème pour moi
c'est une des difficultés majeures pour
moi elle réside vraiment sur la question
des seuils parce que je pense que cette
rigidité qu'on met dans la loi c'est
l'incapacité qu'ensuite on a à pouvoir
s'adapter et toutes ces difficultés
autour des discussions du pass vaccinale
est ce que ça vous fait part regretté
finalement de n'avoir pas choisi la
vaccination obligatoire ce débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire je sais qu'il
est porté de pour le coup depuis le
début par notamment le parti socialiste
la question c'est l'effectivité ensuite
de la mesure que vous mettez en place le
pass sanitaire le pass vaccinale vous
pouvez contrôler et vérifier c'est à
dire un moment vous ne l'avez pas vous
entrez dans un restaurant et bien en
fait vous êtes qu'elle est depuis hier
c'est pareil sur un certain nombre de
lieux de culture de sport explications
macky sall concrètement comment vous
contrôlez on va faire des contrôles
aléatoires dans la rue pour vérifier que
les personnes de plus de 80 ans c'est ce
qui se passe ou pour beaucoup de choses
obligatoires finalement la vérification
elle n'est donné qu'à ceux qui sont
normalement censé le faire c'est à dire
les forces de l'ordre en fait on a
souvent fait le parallèle avec les onze
vaccin obligatoire pour les enfants sauf
que c'est complètement différent si
votre enfant n'a pas séance vaccins
obligatoires la sanction elle est
immédiat c'est à dire qu'il ne peut pas
être inscrits à la crèche ou à l'école
et donc on peut immédiatement vérifié au
regard de son carnet de santé si oui ou
non il a bien ces vaccins protection
pour lui-même et pour les autres la dent
quête de personnes qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés mais qui n'entreraient pas
forcément dans les lieux de culture qui
n'entreraient pas aux restaurants ou
cafés qui n'entreraient pas dans des
lieux de vie de brassage comme là ça
existe avec le pass sanitaires et demain
que le pass vaccinale vue désolé je ne
crois pas que mettre en place demain et
contrôles aléatoires dans la rue puis
après vous faites quoi concrètement la
personne qui n'est pas vaccinée vous
avez contrôler manière aléatoire dans la
rue vous l'emmener de force se faire
vacciner vous la mettez reclus chez elle
en lui disant maintenant où vous
interdit tout serait pourtant le chef de
l'état le chef de l'état est optionnelle
it et le chef de l'état lloris était
complètement la porte à cette
vaccination obligatoire non mais je sais
que ce débat est ce que ça veut dire qui
est ce que ça voulait dire qu'elle sera
mise en place peut-être plus tard on
voit l'italie le met en place pour les
plus de 50 ans l'allemagne va en
discuter au parlement le chansonnier
s'est dit favorable pourrait être mise
en place en allemagne est ce que la
france ne va pas suivre en tout cas la
question que moi je pose quel encore une
fois la question à la fois de la
proportionnalité de cette mesure ont dit
que le pass vexman au passé ni d'heure
serait attentatoire aux libertés
publiques alors qu'à la fin des fins
qu'est ce qui se passe on vous demande
quand même de vous faire vacciner pour
éviter développer des formes peu graves
et d'aller en réanimation et présenter
un qr code pour pouvoir aller dans un
restaurant ou dans un théâtre c'est
quand même ça la contrainte qu'on fait
peser sur vous qui me semble être tout à
fait raisonnable en revanche
l'obligation de vous faire vacciner qui
conduirait potentiellement à quoi est-ce
que vous soyez place à l isolement si
vous refusez vous faire vacciner il ya
quand même un sujet derrière de
proportionnalité encore une fois des
mesures de la mesure qui serait fixé de
risque à mon avis de censure du conseil
consultatif et de risques même
d'efficacité de risque que cette mesure
elle le soit pour le coup absolument pas
accepter autres modifications qui ont
été apportées par les sénateurs celle de
la suppression de la vérification
d'identité par les responsables de bars
cafés et restaurants alors il pointe
notamment les risques de violence envers
les personnes chargées de ces contrôles
je vois que vous ètes dubitative
possibilités parce que les personnes qui
potentiellement pourrait être violent
dans ces cas là elle le serait déjà à la
simple demande de présentation du pass
sanitaire aujourd'hui et ça n'est pas
parce qu'il ya un risque que certaines
personnes soient violente il faut
combattre cette violence plutôt que de
la contourner là encore je trouve que
c'est assez incohérent de la part de l
air de dire attention comme ya un risque
que certaines personnes qu'on tourne et
bien allégeons encore plus les mesures
en vigueur sachant que c'était juste une
mesure de bon sens qui était de dire
parfois on se retrouve avec nous le
disent d'ailleurs des restaurateurs et
cafetiers ou autres qui voient en poste
sanitaire au nom d'un homme alors que
c'est une femme qui se présentait à eux
ou l' inverse ou avec un âge qui de
manière flagrante ne correspond pas à la
personne qu'ils ont en face d'eux et ils
n'ont pas de moyen de dire semblablement
votre pass n'est ce que vous entendez
malgré tout lors leurs critiques de la
part ajustement de certains cafetiers et
restaurateurs qui disent ce n'est pas
notre job il ya des forces de l'ordre
qui sont qui sont là pour pour ça on ne
veut pas se transformer en cerbère du
pass vaccinale oui mais leur intérêt
c'est quoi notre intérêt collectif c'est
quoi c'est de ne pas avoir demain de
confinement c'est de ne pas avoir de
couvre feu c'est de ne pas avoir de
fermeture d'un certain nombre de ces
lieux et donc je préfère encore une fois
qui est un peu plus de contraintes et
donc peut-être de contrôle à l'entrée
plutôt que de prendre le risque de leur
dire va vous aller refermer et en vérité
dans un certain nombre de cas il
contrôle déjà quand vous allez dans un
café et puis dans le même café vous vous
devez pouvoir consommer de l'alcool ou
acheter des cigarettes normalement ils
sont supposés vérifier votre âge par
exemple essentiellement vous demander
votre or berger ça ne gêne personne vous
avez l'air dubitatif voire réticente à
toutes les modifications qui ont été
votée cette nuit par le sénat est ce que
ça veut dire que l'accord députés
sénateurs il ne sera trouvée que sur le
texte des députés c'est soit le talus de
député je vois rien
la ligne rouge absolue c'est sur la
question de l'inscription des seuils
dans la loi parce que je pense tous là
ce peut se discuter je pense qu'après il
peut y avoir des discussions des
compromis qui peuvent être trouvées on
peut pouvoir et par exemple sur la
question du télétravail peut-être qu'un
compromis peut être trouvé sur le
montant qui serait celui potentiellement
de l'amande style théâtral n'étaient pas
respectés fin donc ça ça s'appelle jeu
compromis du débat parlementaire et ses
5 il existe et c'est toute cette journée
pas la porte à toutes les modifications
du semnon je ferme pas la porte parce
que sinon defacto ça voudrait dire qu'on
ne souhaiterait pas qu'ils me commission
mixte paritaire qui fonctionne et ça
retarderait la mise en place du pass big
stal par contre on peut pas accepter à
tout prix un accord si cet accord vient
fragiliser le fait même de mettre en
place le pass un mot sur la décision du
tribunal administratif de versailles est
requis
suspendu le port du masque en extérieur
dans votre département des yvelines
c'est une première en france le tribunal
qui estime que cette décision de port du
masque est une atteinte excessive et
disproportionnée à la liberté
individuelle qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette décision moi j'ai pas à
commenter des facto une décision qui est
prise d'un tribunal administratif ce que
je sais c'est que le préfet va reprendre
un arrêté qui sera plus circonscrit sur
un certain nombre de lieux on a des
lieux où on a absolument besoin que ce
port du masque puisse exister aussi
parce qu'encore une fois on parle
souvent de ceux qui rechignent à un
certain nombre de contraintes on parle
moins de ceux qui souhaitent aussi que
cela puisse être mis en place parce
qu'ils ne se sentent pas sinon en
sécurité d'aller se déplacer dans un
certain nombre de numéros g cette
décision et fragilise une partie de la
stratégie du gouvernement en tout cas
nous on a un département où il y avait
en effet un rebond épidémie qui était
extrêmement important donc sa légitime
et il me sembla décision du préfet qui
était de dire face à un rebond
épidémique encore une fois qu'est ce qui
vaut mieux s qu'il faut des décisions
qui soient un peu brutale de risque de
fermeture de lieux où est ce qu'il vaut
mieux juste porter le masque dans
l'espace public finalement c'est à la
fin on doit continuer à porter le masque
par exemple sur les marchés
souvenez-vous dans le premier
confinement on avait dû au tout début
fermer les marchés qui sont des lieux en
portant de vie économique mais aussi de
vis social on a rouvert les marchés avec
une contrainte raisonnable qui encore
une fois celle du port du masque je
pense qu'on va réussir à trouver un
couple concernant les restrictions
toujours vous aviez vous avez dit sur
rtl qu'il faudrait aller peut-être
encore plus loin et c'est vrai que vous
avez remis sur la sur la table l'idée du
pass sanitaire en entreprise
est-ce que c'est définitivement derrière
nous ça ou est-ce que garder dans un
coin de tête l'idée de le porter à
l'assemblée nationale alors on a porté
ce débat à l'assemblée nationale moi
j'avais porté ses amendements et donc on
les a présentés et on a eu cette
discussion ce que je comprends c'est que
les partenaires sociaux aujourd'hui ne
souhaite pas que ça puisse entrer en
vigueur mais de l'autre côté on a nous
dans tous nos départements des
employeurs mais aussi des salariés qui
nous interpelle sur le sujet des
salariés qui nous disent écoutez moi
dans mon métier c'est très difficile
d'arriver à maintenir les gestes
barrières on est dans des petites
entreprises donc on sait defacto qui est
vacciné qui ne l'est pas on n'a pas
envie de côtoyer des gens qui se mettent
en lice mais qui nous met au risque
aussi au quotidien donc non en fait on
n'a pas les moyens de faire autrement on
est obligés nous de continuer à devenir
travailler avec le risque potentiel
d'être contaminés vous y est favorable
nous mêmes en tout cas moi j'entends les
demandes qui proviennent encore une fois
et de chefs d'entreprises et de salariés
qui nous disent a créé de la tension
parce qu'on sait à la fin dans toutes
petites entreprises notamment qui est
vacciné qui ne l'est pas donc cette
tension elle peut exister au sein du
groupe de travail et que nous dise un
moment comment on fait pour mieux
protéger nos salariés et en tant que
salarié comment on fait pour
éventuellement aussi j'étais de côtoyer
des gens qui se mettrait volontairement
risque on va parler de la grève dans les
écoles aujourd'hui qui s'annonce très
suivie julien oui grève massive et qui
qui va concerner tous les a tous les
secteurs avec des chiffres exceptionnels
de mobilisation 75% ça c'est vraiment
qu'elle a que la prévision ce sera a
précisé aujourd'hui ce que vous
comprenez cette colère contenue de ce
qui peut apparaître comme une valse
hésitation des protocoles sanitaires à
l'endroit de l'éducation nationale moi
je comprends la tension dans laquelle
les enseignants sont ça oui parce que ça
fait deux ans qu'on vit tous dans une
période de pandémie qui en permanence
génère de l'incertitude
qui fait qu'on a du mal à envisager
sereinement l'avenir qu'ils ont des
élèves qui eux mêmes parfois peuvent
être anxieux ça dépend plus des
catégories d'âge la manière avec
laquelle les protocoles peuvent être mis
en place donc ça je peux comprendre et
je peux entendre cette tension en
revanche pour moi le préalable que nous
avons posée est que nous manquons c'est
l'ouverture des écoles et le maintien de
l'ouverture des écoles et moi je suis
désolé mais je me félicite qu'on soit le
pays de l'union européenne qui a le
moins fermer ses écoles pendant
l'intégralité la crise les impôts il ya
d'autres pays qui les ont fermé un peu
brandi comme un totem de la famille
tardivement la majorité présidentielle
mais quand on voit le nombre de classes
fermées quand on voit la désorganisation
dans les écoles l'incertitude
quotidienne dans laquelle sont les
parents est ce que c'était vraiment la
bonne solution et est ce que il n'ya pas
une forme d'hypocrisie de dire mais oui
nous on a gardé les écoles ouvertes
quand on relève des organisations dans
les écoles alors je crois que déjà
encore une fois face à la crise et face
à la pandémie et face à la contagiosité
de ce variant tous les pays sont
confrontés à des organisations qui
concerne pas que l'école qui concerne
aussi nos entreprises c'est pour ça
aussi justement qu'on a changé les
protocoles pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya
plus de mise en isolement de ceux qui
sont qu'à contacter parce que sinon on
mettait finalement d'isolement quasiment
tout le pays parce que vraisemblablement
vu le risque de contagiosité on va tous
soient un moment être contaminés soit en
tout cas être qu'à contacter donc il y
avait besoin de s'adapter et donc il ya
aussi le besoin d'adapter notre école il
ya aussi besoin d'adapter les protocoles
sanitaires mais le but sera quasiment en
une semaine oui mais encore une fois on
nous demande de l'adapter c'est-à-dire
au départ les enseignants nous ont dit
un seul tu es ça ne suffit pas parce que
le premier test peut être négatif mais
finalement la manière avec laquelle on
peut être innovant peu le virus peut
être inoculé fait que bach deux jours
trois jours quatre jours après un autre
test aurait pu se révéler positif donc
on se sent pas suffisamment protégés
face aux enfants qui sont là et qui
peuvent être porteurs donc faisons
plusieurs têtes on a donc mis en place
le fait qu'ils aient plusieurs textes
ensuite on a entendu les infos 10 c'est
la faute des enseignants jeudi par août
il ya des conseils sanitaires mais aussi
ce qu'on a besoin d'accepter que sur ce
sujet là oui on a un choix politique que
ce choix politiques et les de dire il
faut maintenir les écoles ouvertes je
suis désolée la seule alternative que
les oppositions nous est proposé c'est
de dire reporter la rentrée mais
reporter la rentrée ça veut dire
supprimer une semaine de cours et ça
aurait changé quoi concrètement ça
aurait on aurait dit aux parents le
vendredi ou le samedi écouter à partir
de lundi pendant une semaine vous allez
reprendre vos enfants chez vous pour
celles et ceux qui déjà
pouvait c'est quand même loin d'être le
cas pour tous les parents avec encore
une fois les risques d'inégalité dont on
sait tous on sait très bien que ça
génère quand on a une fermeture d'école
tes parents qui sont en situation garder
leurs enfants et pouvoir leur faire
cours ou accompagner les cours donnés
par les enseignants et d'autres qu'ils
ne peuvent absolument pas le faire et au
bout d'une semaine on aurait eu quoi
alors qu'on était en plein rebond
épidémique en france il faudrait mieux
continuer finalement reporté d'une
deuxième semaine que d'une troisième
semaine puis ça aurait fini avec un mois
et puis ce serait bien en fait
finalement on reporte jusqu'aux
prochaines vacances scolaires donc ce
n'était pas une fin pour moi ce n'était
pas acceptable que la seule réponse
apportée ce soit de dire on ferme les
écoles donc je dis pas que la réponse
elle est idéale je sais bien qu'elle ne
l'est pas et pour les enseignants et
pour les parents et même pour les
enfants qui doivent aussi réaliser ou
parfois subir les tests on le voit bien
je vois là on côtoie tous des enfants
qui n'ont pas forcément envie et on les
comprend d'avoir un écouvillon d'emmener
pour réaliser un test je vois bien aussi
ce que ça peut représenter par contre je
crois qu'ils ont surtout aussi envie de
pouvoir retourner à l'école parce qu'ils
voient bien l'enjeu que c'est et les
parents préfèrent aussi que leurs
enfants y avait que les enseignants
préfèrent aussi enseigné les dernières
questions sur ce sujet oui est ce que
est ce que par rapport à quand même à
cette hésitation autour du protocole et
par rapport aux la colère des
enseignants est ce que jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ne se retrouvent pas
fragiliser d'aisé on sait qu'il ya des
critiques viennent aussi de de la
majorité a coûté en tout cas elles
viendront pas de ma part parce que moi
je considère que déjà c'est une chance
pour une fois d'avoir eu un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui sera resté
l'intégralité d'un quinquennat ce qui
n'est quand même à peu près jamais
arrivé ce qui est une question quand
même qui peut tous nous interroger sur
des vrais des véritables politiques
publiques et à changer un moment nos
modèles d'éducation je pense que ça
c'est le premier point 2 parce qu'encore
une fois ci on a tenu la barre si on a
tenu les écoles ouvertes c'est justement
parce qu'on avait un mini suffisamment
solides et qui n'a jamais lâché sur ses
arbitrages là sinon on aurait pu se
retrouver comme l'allemagne comme la
grande-bretagne comme l'italie avec six
à neuf mois de fermeture moi je
m'interroge et on le verra dans cinq ans
dans dix ans sur les conséquences
éducatives sociales psychologiques pour
ces enfants qui n'auront quasiment pas
eu accès à des cours accès à la
sociabilité accès à leurs enseignants
pendant toute une année j'aimerais
parler de la violence envers les élus
oui alors aux violences qui est que vous
avez dénoncé vous même dans une
interview la aux bougies au journal du
dimanche wauquiez une prise de
conscience collective concernant les
violences et menaces qui se multiplient
est ce que vous pensez avoir été entendu
en tout cas nous on a eu à l'assemblée
nationale sous l'égide du président de
l'assemblée nationale
l'ensemble des présidents de groupes qui
ont fait front comment moi c'est ce à
quoi j'appelais parce que je pense que
c'est nécessaire c'est à dire que les
violences qui sont faites aux élus que
soient les parlementaires ou les mères
puisque on voit que des maires ont été
notamment justement face à la question
sanitaire souvent malheureusement pris à
partie son atelier avec des agressions
oui mais le problème c'est qu'on
employer cette expression populaire
c'était le problème c'est que l'image
est devenue réelle avec des agressions
regardez mon collègue stéphane claireaux
élus d'outre-mer qui parce que lui dans
un territoire ou en effet on a
malheureusement un record de faible
vaccination a eu le courage de dire - ma
responsabilité d'élus c'est d'appeler à
la vaccination c'est ça le courage d'un
élu un moment c'est parfois d'aller
contre aussi une partie de la population
même
l'image ça les conforte âgées parce que
cette image d'unité de l'assemblée
nationale elle est nécessaire c'est un
symbole on m'aide a quand même mais
c'est pas cette image qui va régler le
problème concrètement des violences
envers les élus qu'est ce qu'on fait est
ce qu'il faut prendre d'autres mesures
moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
changer la loi la loi aujourd'hui elle
est extrêmement clair sur les violences
qui existe sur tous les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique quel qu'il soit on
l'a même renforcé dans notre proposition
de sécurité globale on a par exemple
supprimer les remises de peine
automatiques qui existait quand il y
avait des violences sur les forces de
l'ordre les pompiers les anciens ou les
élus donc l'arsenal législatif il existe
alors pour confondre le lancerons
toujours crescendo alors déjà moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'on continue nous
systématiquement non seulement à
dénoncer mais a porté plainte ce que
j'ai fait parce que certaines plantes
peuvent aboutir parce que nos services
de police de gendarmerie de
renseignements font le travail pour
identifier celles et ceux qui à un
moment nous menace nous intimer de voir
même nous agressent physiquement vous
avez déposé combien de plaintes
franchement j'y suis allé quatre fois
mais à chaque fois avec un paquet un peu
fournis
j'en ai une qui a abouti avec une
personne qui a été condamnée avec trois
mois avec sursis mais c'est une
condamnation ça veut dire que c'est une
épée de damoclès des ormes sur sa tête
et c'est aussi envoyer un signal de dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'impunité et que ce
n'est pas parce que vous publiez sur les
réseaux sociaux que cette impunité doit
exister mais il ya deux sujets il ya la
coopération des plateformes qui n'est
pas toujours extrêmement réactive et je
suis poli quand je dis ça mais c'est une
nécessité c'est à dire à partir du
moment où vous avez des gens qui
clairement vos menaces vous intimider je
ne parle même pas des insultes ces gens
là deux raies de plus pouvoir bénéficier
de comptes sur les réseaux sociaux il
devrait y avoir une coopération très
forte et très rapide entre les services
de police et de justice et les
différentes plateformes et on a besoin
aussi d'une exemplarité ensuite dans la
sanction on ne peut pas avoir face à des
menaces qui ont été proférées wade en
timide à sion uniquement à rappel à la
loi et je pense que là dessus il faut
être très clair celles et ceux qui nous
menacent où nous intimident compte un
but clair faire en sorte que nous
changions de conviction faire en sorte
que finalement nous renoncions à venir à
l'assemblée nationale sénart dans nos
municipalités 15 ans en fait donc il ya
trop de l'alsace judiciaire sur ces
questions parce qu'en tout cas moi je
demandais ce que soit pris au sérieux
parce que l'enjeu démocratique est là
mais diront peut pas venir par exemple
si imaginons que demain on est dedans ou
votre à l'assemblée nationale soient les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire soit on re débattra on ne peut
pas avoir des parlementaires qui ont
peur de venir parce qu'ils auraient peur
de conséquences physiques des risques
d'agression qu'il subirait demain une
dernière question gère oui juste un
petit mot sur le lait les parrainages on
sait qu'ils font débat à l'heure
actuelle est ce que selon vous il faut
modifier les règles non pour moi il faut
pas modifier les règles c'est une règle
scène qui avait été mise en place par le
général de gaulle d'ailleurs on a besoin
d'un bon il ya trois tours dans une
élection présidentielle il ya un premier
tour qui est d'arriver à convaincre
aussi que celles et ceux qui renoue
représente dans l'ensemble des
territoires sont suffisamment convaincu
de la crédibilité de votre candidature
pour donner leurs parrainages et ça n'a
pas empêché qu'on est à certaines
élections présidentielles me semble une
grande variété et diversité de candidats
ça veut dire que c'est possible chaque
canal mâcon quand il était candidat à la
dernière élection présidentielle il
n'avait pas de parti politique et ils
n'avaient pas non plus énormément d'élus
locaux et en commande parlementaire donc
c'est à dire que c'est possible et qu'il
faut faire ce travail de conviction est
qu'il faut et on en revient un peu au
sujet précédent que les maires
évidemment ce sont libres de parrainer
qui le souhaitent merci beaucoup merci
robert gels d'avoirs et aidé à
travailler c'est ce matin même
[Musique]